You
It looks like those frogs with butts.
Yeah, you know what I'm talking about?
It's, I believe it's called a grease glass.
I don't like grease glass.
That's what all the grease is made.
That just doesn't look real to me.
It's like my brain doesn't want to.
I know, same.
I'm just like.
Where's the tail?
Is that your guinea pig?
No, I do.
I used to own guinea pigs, but that's
why I knew they don't have tails.
Oh, OK.
This is your butt, though.
It's my butt.
Oh my god, look at the little feet.
Yeah, they have little rat feet.
They are very rat-like.
I mean, they are rodents.
I'm allergic to guinea pigs and rodents.
You should be honestly fine with guinea pigs.
I think guinea pigs are pretty good with people who have allergies.
I'm allergic to rabbits and I'm allergic to guinea pigs.
Don't ask me why I'm a rabbit and I'm allergic to rabbits.
This is how things are.
Can I ask you why you're allergic to guinea pigs?
Because my friend had a guinea pig,
and I would always get itchy and like, sneeze-y.
That's crazy.
Guinea pigs are like one of the harder animals to be allergic to.
I guess I win that that.
I'm allergic to animals that I wish I could love,
but I can't because they make me sneeze.
This is a shame.
You can't even love yourself.
I know I can't.
It stinks.
Last time I hung out with a bunny,
I almost went into anaphylactic shock.
It was, again, a travesty.
You know, I have a friend with seven cats.
And my roommate's like heavily allergic cats.
Oh, gosh.
So we go over and even with like air purifiers
and it cleaned the place regularly,
it like, he dies after like an hour.
Oh, no.
Natural selection.
Oh, my God.
Amy's going to kill me.
She's like, I'm sorry,
she be we have to make room for the strong
and then she just cuts my head off or something.
I don't know.
She just sticks her out.
I don't know if I'm allergic to rats.
I'll be on our mice.
I don't know.
They're not they're not particularly fluffy creatures.
Yeah.
Are they hot or something?
It's like the spit.
It's a spit.
No, but they're soft.
Rats are really soft.
I can't be back in the school.
You touched a rat.
Mm-hmm.
Like.
What do you want to say?
Go ahead.
You know, I'm going to say,
I'm going to hold my tongue on this one.
No, no, no, no, go ahead, say it, go ahead, say it, say it.
I know you're going to bully me later.
No, no, no, no, say me my bully, though.
You mean my bully?
Say it.
I'm not going to say it.
I'm going to say it.
Don't you own rats?
I do.
Yeah, yeah, say it, go ahead, say it.
I'm not trying to get beat up.
I'm trying to get beat up here.
Self-preservation.
She will survive me.
Not so much.
That's awesome.
It's like that.
It's like that scene from Ben 10 with Kevin.
He's like, you got to treat a woman like you treat your car.
And the girl is like, yeah, go on.
And he's like, no.
I swear it's not the same.
It's the way you bring up the scene every time I talk to you.
You know what's crazy?
I think it was like, honestly, seven-year-old me.
Whenever they came out with like teen Ben 10,
I thought Kevin was so hot.
You're not wrong.
Kevin, who?
Sorry, Emmy is the ultimate zoomer.
Kevin 11.
Wait.
I think it's Kevin 11.
Yeah, Kevin 11.
Kevin 11.
And he has like a car?
Yeah.
No, no, no, no.
OK, OK, there's like an ugly one.
Wait, I want to see.
How did this age, because I haven't seen that show in a long time.
Oh, wait, no.
OK, wait, yeah.
There's like, there's an ugly one where he kind of looks
like a stoner and he does not look good.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
No, not him.
No.
It was a different version.
No, I think I see the version you mean.
Yeah, OK, there we go.
With the black t-shirt and the gray sleeve.
Yeah, that's the one.
That's the hotline.
OK, OK, OK.
I see what you mean.
They were judging us.
She was like, what stoner ass?
The first picture I saw, I was like.
You look fine back in the day.
Oh, it was like the alien.
No, no, no, no, no.
Maybe Viv likes the alien.
Yeah, four arms is hot.
OK, maybe we should start the game.
Or we should introduce ourselves.
Oh, yeah, yeah, that's it.
Oh, I just see everyone new, but that's my bad.
Not everyone knows.
It's OK.
We can.
Because the only people that matter are the four people
in this call, and we love each other.
I'm going to ask, are these the friends?
What's wrong with that?
What do you mean, are these the friends?
Of course, they're my friends.
Hi, I'm friends.
Are these the two friends you have, the three?
You not count, right?
Did you say two?
I didn't count myself, yeah.
She's more than a friend.
She's my wife.
She's her twin flame.
We could have been roommates.
Do you guys think, so what is a twin flame?
Is that like a soulmate?
It's a cult.
What?
No.
It's a cult.
No, no, no, that's that.
That's something else in me.
No.
A twin flame is usually someone that you're
meant to have a relationship in a karmic cycle.
And it's very hot and burny.
And it can actually be pretty toxic,
but very passionate and loving at the same time.
But they're not your soulmate.
It's like a shitty soulmate.
A shitty soulmate?
Yeah, that's us.
I beat her in game pigeon, and then I laugh at her.
OK, to be fair, I was going to go easy on her,
and then she said, you're going down.
Oh, she does play pool.
It's terrible.
I thought they would like that.
I thought they'll make it hotter for you.
She did.
So we played eight ball, and then she
made fun of me for a bad play, and then she immediately
hit the eight ball into the hole, and she lost.
I'm not sure if we're first round.
I didn't know how eight ball works.
I didn't know, like, you literally couldn't touch the eight.
I didn't know.
It was unlucky for me.
I mean, we should probably introduce ourselves.
Sorry, I'm reading my chat because they're like, wait,
isn't that like in the Will Smith movie in Hancock?
And I totally forgot that that is part of that movie.
What is?
The Twin Flames something, really.
But it is a cult.
You're right.
Yeah.
I only know the cult one.
It's all you need here.
OK.
OK, hi, hi, hi, everyone.
Hi, chat.
I'm Amy.
I'm from Vealer.
Yeah.
Yeah, nice to meet you.
Almost.
That's fair.
Who wants to go next?
If no one raises their hand, I'm going to choose.
OK, I won't be volatile.
Um, hi.
Hello there.
My name is Sheebie Cottonbum of Gen 1, Vealers, Indulge.
And I'm your favorite dorky girl failure, Dom, failure.
What?
She already fucked it up.
Yeah.
Good job, Sheebie.
I tried my best.
Viv, do you want to go first?
You want me?
Yeah, OK, I guess I'll go.
Hi, I'm Vivian Voss.
You're a good biker babe.
Nice to meet you.
You're a biker?
Yeah.
Like a tricycle?
She doesn't even know what to say.
She just stared at the camera like, what the fuck did she just say?
I need to take a really big breath after that one.
I would have anger management issues.
She was having flashbacks to something else.
No, it's a unicycle.
She's the only human.
Wait, actually, no, Amy's human.
Are you human?
I thought you were like a, what is it called?
A gamer.
I hate you.
I have a different race.
I'm a gamer.
I mean, look at that dent.
Oh, she just has that dent.
Chad, you guys didn't know this, but we were in call
and we were talking about something completely different.
And then I just went, why do you have a dent?
And I never noticed that he has a lovely cute dent in her head.
I can rest my booba in it.
That's why it's dented.
Because it's totally not mine.
I actually kind of want that as a photo.
Me just like picking her up and tucking her under my breast.
This is just holding her closely to my bosom.
That was fair.
I was like that, too.
All right, so am I the only one who's played this before?
I haven't done my intro.
Oh, I'm leaving.
I'm just going to be down here.
I'm Sopralta, also Nana Safi.
I'm a guinea pig.
I have a nice butt, apparently.
That's it.
We didn't say nice.
I know.
I have a nice butt.
Confounding.
I mean, it's a butt, all right.
Something.
OK, I don't have a tail.
I mean, your butt hangs kind of low.
Oh, you got a long back or something like that.
Oh, are you talking about her guinea pig butt?
Yeah, her guinea pig butt.
She's just mad.
I said she rides a bicycle.
A tricycle.
Oh, a tricycle, yeah.
OK, we should start this game before she kills me.
OK, I'm starting it.
Has anybody played the game?
Oh, my piramid is back.
We have played before.
Vivi's going to kill us.
Wait, who's in the middle?
OK, so we got Emmy and Sopralta on the ends.
Very interesting.
Emmy.
Emmy, what?
No, you might.
I actually think I trust you more than Sopralta.
What?
I'll have you know.
Even though you've never played before.
What is the end like an important task?
Yes.
There's no God here.
Only name and people.
Oh, I can pull you guys in.
Oh, I'll pull you in.
I figure how to pull.
How do I pull?
It's easy like look at them.
Are we both an old man?
Yeah, they're both an old white man.
I specifically chose the old man.
And I'm pretty surprised for being an old guy.
Pretty fly for an old guy.
We are barefoot.
What the heck?
No, no, no, don't let them look.
Don't let them look.
OK, cover it with the chains at all times.
It's not too hard so far.
Oh, walking.
The boy said about not trusting me.
Don't do it.
Just immediately, but begging.
You guys can't see.
See what?
See he's not in your mouth.
You can't see my how can you not see my game?
Pull me.
Just pull me.
I'm pulling the one.
OK.
Pull it in.
Oh, it lagged.
It lagged.
It's still in the character selection screen for everyone.
How is that happening?
Were you showing window capture or were you showing game
capture?
Oh, OK.
OK, now it's working.
Now it's working.
OK, I don't know why it did that.
I'm going to lock in.
Time to lock in.
Apologies.
I put normal motion when I remember.
So do you want to have countdown?
Do you want to have countdown?
Countdowns.
No, we don't do countdowns.
OK, we just go for it.
We just read each other's minds and hope for the best.
You know what we kind of look like?
So Stan, Ford, Mabel, and Wendy.
Oh, you're not wrong.
What is that?
From Gravity Falls.
All right, go in order.
Or not, that's fine.
We've gotten this far.
I'm just waiting for one of us to fall off.
Well, he's like, you want me to fall off?
No.
Did you just say fall off?
Well, if you do, we can just pull you back up, I guess.
Is that a bet?
Yep, bet.
Do it.
Throw yourself off.
Did you just say fall off?
Did you just do it?
Mabel, pull us up.
Go, go, go!
OK, OK, OK.
You're too heavy.
Grab, grab, grab, grab.
Oh, sorry.
Oh.
Hail.
Amy, swing on the other side.
Jump off the other side.
All right, I can just stand here, can I?
We're going to fall off!
No, just fall, just fall.
It's literally, we're just going to fall to the bottom.
It's OK.
I'm standing.
I'm actually fine.
Oh, no, I'm swinging again.
Oh, OK, wait.
We're literally almost at the end.
Come on.
Amy with the carry.
How did she manage that?
She's a gamer.
I think we should leave Sepral.
No, OK.
We should cut her off at the end.
So you can't leave me.
I should have eaten you in the womb.
Don't fall off in the hole.
Oh, does that fall off?
Oh, my God.
Do you have selective hearing?
I mean, I am an old guy.
You got to adjust your hearing aid, brother.
All right, so don't touch that.
Oh, my God.
I'm sorry.
Guys, guys, guys.
Amy, Amy, pull us up.
Amy.
I can't.
I'm going to fall if I turn around.
No, OK.
Just pull this back up, back up.
You see that thingy?
What the?
The little stick.
Why don't you jump on the other side of the stick
and then we can like...
Or you can back up on the rock.
I can't jump.
And then press E?
Someone's going to write.
Better idea, better idea.
OK, there we go.
Can you guys...
Can you come up from here or no?
Can you pull me?
What for you?
Can you come up here for me?
Can I come up?
I'll come in for you.
OK.
Help me, please.
Thank you.
OK, too bad.
I can't wait.
We've only gotten this far.
We're not even at like the crazy part yet.
Wait, what do you mean?
No, this is not...
You're telling me we haven't even gotten past the tutorial?
No, this is literally still a tutorial.
This is a tutorial?
Essentially.
This kind of gives you a taste of everything.
OK, OK, ready?
So don't touch these.
We have to jump over them.
Can the chain touch it?
Yes, that's fine.
OK.
You can also run.
Don't get hit by that.
And then you can Mario climb the fence.
Mario climb the fence.
You'll see what I mean.
We've literally played this game before.
What do you mean, Mario climb the fence?
Someone said we're just two pairs of the same person.
They're kind of right.
You're not wrong, actually.
I was thinking that earlier.
I didn't want to say it.
How do I get off?
Just press B.
All right.
OK, so there's a trampoline.
So we're just going to...
One, two, three.
Yippee, dude.
Oh, what just happened?
All right.
No, get off.
Get off of it.
All right.
Aim towards the other one.
There you go.
Yippee.
Ah!
OK.
Nice.
Keep going.
Don't worry.
It means we got you.
I'm stressing.
OK.
Now let's go through the tunnel.
We're going the hole.
The hole of love.
The love.
The tunnel.
I love you, baby girl.
I love you too.
Pookie.
Pookie bear.
Sunshine.
No, that's only for me, babe.
That's only for me.
OK.
I know for a fact we're going to fall off this time.
No, no, no.
I got this.
OK, you go first.
You go first.
I don't trust her.
Don't jump like that.
You're making me nervous.
OK.
I can't jump up.
I didn't feel like auto or whatever.
It doesn't for this one.
Sometimes.
Which way do I go?
Like this way?
Follow your heart.
I trust you.
Are you saying that's because I'm Asian?
What?
I didn't even know you were Asian.
I thought you were guinea pig.
Exactly.
I can be both.
I can be Asian.
Are there Asian breeds of guinea pigs?
No.
But you know, coffee bars are loved by all of Asia.
So if you think about it, it's kind of like close enough.
That's true.
They are pretty.
They are the biggest guinea pig.
Coffee bars?
Are they the largest rodents?
Really?
Probably not.
They have like...
Horse hair.
Yeah.
I want to pet one.
Yeah, it's kind of like a broom.
It's like a school.
Have you ever touched a coffee bar?
No, but I'm going on in October to Japan.
I'm going to go touch one.
Nice.
I'm going to see them in the onsen.
I'm going to touch it.
I'm going to pet it.
Are we still talking about coffee bars?
No, I don't think we're allowed to.
If I could...
You can't...
You can't bathe with them?
What's the point?
Hold on.
Okay.
Did you know that they poop in the water?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, so do I.
And?
And the water that you bathed in me?
The bathtub ASMR is about to go crazy.
Where are you?
She took us the long way.
Well, I didn't know there was another direction on my bed.
No, you're fine.
I'm just teasing you.
Wait, there's a short way?
Yeah.
Someone say short?
Like you.
I'm not short.
I'm taller than you.
No, you're not.
Well, how tall are you?
5'2".
No way.
I'm 5'3".
This is my dick.
Wow.
My balls.
Do you think that one inch saves you?
Me here, my 5'8".
Yeah, the one that was in the cedar.
Throwing everybody around.
Oh, my God.
Look at that.
Look at that monster.
He's kind of cute.
Where do we go?
The monster?
Yeah, the monster over here.
Over here.
Over here's a long-ass tongue.
What that tongue do?
He's got a tongue?
I think he has a tongue.
That's a tongue.
He does have a tongue.
Yeah.
I think you can zoom in.
There's a way to do it.
I can't remember how, though.
Is it tilde?
Tilda to zoom in?
Tilda?
No, I think that's to bring up the console, isn't it?
How do you zoom in?
What Emmy needs to figure out is how to spawn us when we fall off, because we can restart
at little checkpoint places.
Oh, we can't?
No, we're a raw dog in it.
You want to start raw dog this?
I think we're going to fail.
We have to do it all in one go.
Which way do we go from here?
Remember that time?
I was just trying to figure it out.
I think we're going to fail.
We have to do it all in one go.
Which way do we go from here?
Remember that time?
We jump on the rock.
And you kept saying stuff about where we find the spawn.
Oh, OK, Emmy.
It looks like we're going, Emmy.
He said, jump on the rock.
He said, where are we going?
And I said, the rock.
And then you're like, OK.
And then you just go.
None of us made a move to go.
Pull me up.
Please pull me up.
You guys are saying we do this all in one go?
You guys are saying?
Let's all agree this is Emmy's fault, and none of us
are ready to go yet.
No, we're joking.
We're jumping on the rock.
We jump on the rock.
I did say, jump.
You asked me, where are we going?
And I said, we're going to that rock.
that rock, and then me every-
Okay, so I went to the-
You knew this way, you knew this way.
Wait, how do I respond?
Tell me the way.
I honestly don't know,
because I think Apollo did it.
Or, when I played with her.
Okay, wait, hold on, let me look it up then.
I think it's like, I think the way it's done is,
something like-
You just press a button.
It's in the menu, right?
Oh, it's a button?
Well, I think it, I don't know.
I'm just guessing.
There is a button that you press.
Are you making out with me,
when I'm your sibling?
Self-sist.
Looks at me.
My friend Hachi would be totally into that.
Mwah, mwah, mwah.
Two identical twin old man.
We have a friend Hachi,
and Hachi loves Genji Ex Hanso.
Honestly, I don't blame her.
What?
I think I'm traumatized again.
From the overwatch.
Did we reach 576 meters?
No.
I don't think we got to-
Oh, sorry, I'm playing on normal mode.
There's no checkpoints on normal mode.
I told you.
All right, no, I'm dogging it.
I don't think this counts as a fall,
because that was our tutorial, you know?
We had to warm up first.
Yeah, that was warm up.
Oh, guys, we are going to-
Ah!
Okay.
Hachi will never live that down.
Nope.
She traumatized me, and now she's stuck with it.
On the pause menu, then teleport
at the center of the screen.
But we are in normal mode, it doesn't have-
Sorry, I thought I didn't want to be a scrub
and choose easy mode, you know?
No, we're gamers.
We're gamers, we got this.
Yeah.
We're stinky gamers.
Of course.
I sour, I'm gonna go about you.
Well, you sour every four days.
That still means I sour.
Is that a problem?
How often do you guys sour?
Not for me, it is.
Oh, we could take the shortcut to the right.
That's a shortcut?
Yeah.
Go for it.
Is it?
Yeah.
Either way, Viv.
I didn't know this was a shortcut.
Me neither.
Why didn't we do this the first time?
I was just following you all the way.
Look, we did it!
We did it!
Nothing to it.
I wonder how far,
I hope we get to at least the car.
There's a car?
You've never gotten to the car?
No, we see, she like rage quit.
Last time we played it.
Who rage quit?
You!
Not even two hours in, she all taps fours.
I may have done that.
You can just move your mouse and like,
slowly turn it as you walk.
No, I'm too nervous.
No, we're still running there.
Someone's slowing us down here.
Yeah, it's freaking me.
If he ends too scared to move forward.
I don't want to follow.
If you're me, Kimber,
I'll catch you, Jinx.
I'll catch you.
Wait, so who's seen Gravity Falls here?
Me.
I've seen a little bit of it.
I found out the other day that apparently Mabel
was supposed to die on the show,
and Disney said no.
I would say no too.
Mabel's really cute.
I love her too.
I love Mabel.
They wanted like a sacrifice kind of thing going on.
No.
And like what's Scar a place of like a,
I can't talk, a generation of kids.
Sorry, I had a brain aneurysm.
Listen, you know, the death of a character.
Like, it's character development.
Look at us insane.
And it was the end of the show.
What more development do you need at the end of the show?
No, no, no.
It was just overall, she was supposed to die.
I don't know where.
Oh, like in general, at some point in the show.
The first pilot episode, they just killed her.
We don't like her.
Get her out of there.
The pilot though, the pilot was such an adult version.
Was it?
You know, you guys can get off here, right?
No, no, no, no.
We're going the whole way.
Just kidding.
How do we get off?
Okay.
We need to run her here.
Already?
Yeah.
Go.
Oh, what?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
How do we not make it?
God, guys.
I don't know if that was my fault or not.
I'm kind of confused.
It was not me, it was the last one.
It was the last one.
I was the last one.
Yeah, it was the last one.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, was she too late?
Are you saying I'm fat?
Are you sure?
You don't want to do the teleport.
Thank God.
Okay, we'd have to leave the...
Yeah, we'd have to leave the game so I can change it to easy mode. I think
No, it's the same map you just be able to teleport to where you fell from
Chat would want us to be in pain
Don't give them chance to respond because we already know what they're gonna say
You guys should totally go in easy mode because yeah, that's what I'm gonna say. I believe I believe you and wait
I'm gonna do double-dutch
What's a double-dutch?
You don't know what the whole touches is that an American thing?
No, it's like a like when you're jump roping. Yeah, it's too. It's two ropes
three people so two people are like
Yeah, you never you never did you ever skip rope in me?
Well, I only did it because I was at a mandated after-school program because I was dumb
Yeah, my chat also said hard motor bust
Can we bust what does bust mean I can bust a move I can't crouch so I can't twerk
I
Can't read your mind y'all
I'm trying my hardest my telepathy is out of
Swap the flats with the the mommies
Oh
It means in me
Is the fight that goes with Shabby's mommy?
And I don't want to live anymore
Shabby is a rabbit and I am a guinea pig so like to we're chilling we're vibing
I could feed her
I'll share my snacks. Yeah, we eat the same food
Yeah, basically, I don't like carrots. What do you like?
Letters won't feed you some lettuce. Do you like arugula?
Arugula, I mean I'll eat it. You like zucchini. My mom just grew some zucchini in our garden. Oh my god
I love zucchini. I'll give you some zucchini. Just don't do anything else
Actually, you know my guinea pigs the ones I own ready
We fed them like exotic Asian fruits
Impressed like what?
Do you guys know like like leechy. Oh, I love leechy. Yeah, we gave them leechy. We gave them
Rambootin. Oh, magazine. Oh
Damn well fed
Yeah, of course guinea pigs are always
Rotons
Okay, so
We gotta
Climb up here, and I can't climb for some reason. Oh
It's this again. Yep, and then we gotta be able to jump on the rocks later if you look up you can see where we are
Look down
Oh
You hear the screams of the dams very nice on beyond how right now
Yeah, I was gonna say it's just reminds me of Florida
No, I've been multiple times
And they had a lot of
They do
Guanas
You got the same me no, I just don't like alligators. They are scary
She's just like
I
Space bar
Okay, all right, don't step on it yet
Am at that stationary rock you rock with the vines. Yeah, ready do it for the vine
Ready. Yeah, two one go
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, and then we got a time this
Yeah, and then we got to just like run and book it. Okay. There's a shift
This shift shift. Okay guys ready. We'll do not the next one
Yes
We're close to the car
No, no, this is hard mode. I don't think there's a hard air mode. I think it's either normal or easy. Yep
No, there was a fun mode. I think I wonder what that would be like
Probably no checkpoints at all
Checkpoints at all iron this one. Okay, jump jump. Okay, so for this ladder
You got a time it because you can see the little thingies the what little spikes. So don't so don't do it yet
All right now we can go
All of us
Maybe it was me. I don't know you can blame me. Okay, blame it on
alcohol, oh
Easier to see them from the side. Oh true duh
So like look at okay, look at them from the side
Okay, I can't
Oh
Okay, this one we're gonna get messed up on a lot, I just sort of know it
I'm just being I'm just being
Look realistic we all have to brain cells and together they make six. I
Was gonna say that makes two
So, you know how where I'm at in this
Oh, it makes a wait two four six eight, okay
You guys want to get to the edge of glory right over here a little closer
We got a time it
Okay, so when it comes back close nice one. Yeah, I'm gonna jump so jump
Don't jump to you got a backboard back up and then oh never mind
Are we stuck
Oh
So we got a jump then jump but you got a kind of like you got like pulled so it's a look at me over here
Well, you guys can see me doesn't matter. I don't know why I'm asking to turn around
So you got a like kind of like jump that then like press the back button to bring yourself backwards
Do you set a lot
So W jump
Space W s space
Okay, you don't want to overshoot it. Yeah, when do we jump let's do the next one not this one
Oh
Excited little jump
What there's a countdown yeah, I just read the chat and they said it's three R
Are what what is this countdown for? Oh time jumping together?
We don't do it at the time
We got this I'm scared
These look like triskets
I want triskets. I don't actually really wait which direction. Oh this way. You don't want to trisk it
It's I don't even know how to see you in it. No, it's like it's like a shredded
You know, you know mini weeks like frosted mini weeks cereal. It's not wait is this
Do it let's not be make us folly fucking asshole. Okay, so if we jump on this we have to know guys
We gotta just you gotta jump jump jump jump
I gotta put more faith in us, then I'm sorry
We're gamers
Oh
Wait, where do we go from here to the side? Oh, okay. There we go. Yeah, do we go up?
There's our house. This is where we live
Now we can play family
basement
I'll be
I'll be the stern mother that works
I
Mean is literally a pit of me up a potato flew around
Okay, so this has lasers that will knock us off does anybody want to take a rest in the hut before we continue
There's no crash
This is the goon shack
I found out the other day what what a female gooner is. What's a female gooner?
A good net. Yeah, goonette. That sounds like a band
Supralto and the goonette
Okay, jump when it gets close to you
Nice job
I don't know where we go from here
Jump to the right no jump up here
Run yeah, yeah, ready one two three go
Okay, ready, okay, ready. We're gonna jump to wait. We're all the trampoline
Trampoline go. Okay. Nice. Nice. Nice. Don't land on the trampoline. Oh my god
We're fine
I don't really know what's happening again, Amy carrying us
I can't get up. Hey, Amy. Amy. Actually, you know what I want you to do
Can you grab that hook? Can you jump up and grab it?
Okay
Okay, I'm grabbing it
When do I let go? Don't let go
You'll know when just don't let go
Or I will cry profusely
Well, how am I supposed to know when I when I because we're gonna be near a platform. Don't worry
You'll you'll know you'll know deep in your heart
Okay
We're almost there. Here we are. It's the car. Okay, you can let go now
Okay, so whoever gets in the car first will drive who wants to try it wait wait, but before we go
Let me explain
Okay, there are obstacles you may fall off the map if we fall off the map, but then we got to do this all over. Okay
Okay, not it
Not it. I don't trust here. I don't trust you. You're the you're the you're the biker. Yeah. Yeah, you're a biker
You should know what you're doing. Don't go too fast. Don't go too fast. Oh my god
Don't be speeding now
He's in my face
You don't you guys don't trust me
What do you mean there's rocks please watch out for the rocks and the whole
Oh
You don't trust me. I'm hearing a lot of doubt in your voice right now a lot of doubt
I'm so scared
Amazing job, honestly, I'm coughing right now
I can't recall if this is a checkpoint or not
Yeah, I don't oh my god, I was laughing so hard. No, they're in the no like even even in the normal. They're like checkpoints
Oh my god, I was crying
Have you gotten this far before no, okay, let me explain
So, okay, I see it's twisting. Oh, yeah, so you literally just have to run. Don't do it yet
In jump and kind of like you got to like jump on it
Yeah, when did my model change? Oh, what?
Why are you a different dude?
I was an old guy and now I'm not
Holy shit, you got you you're not the new character
I can't believe you changed when we got in the probably when we got in the car my chance
No, no, no, I was still the old guy when we were in the car. Was it when we got out? Maybe
You're driving made me like
And it made me probably age even more I just absorbed your elderlyness
Okay, okay, so literally you just have to stand on top of it after you climb to the top and just jump with the spins
Huh, okay. I did not understand
Yeah, you just jump in general so
So you can jump onto it now. Good luck
And then just stand and it's gonna rotate. I can't even get up, bro
There we go, we're fine
Then jump good job amazing ladies and jump
And then jump off
I'm like stuck in
Nice job guys
Okay, this one we just have to like climb it's not really a big deal. Okay. How do we climb this? Oh, we jump when it gets closer
Yeah, I I can't time things correctly. So I'll just let you guys carry
Yeah, I never said I was good at it. I just remember stuff
I'm trying to pull. It's just not working out for you
Why won't you get up here? That's so weird. I don't know. I can't climb it. No, no, I can't do anything
That's why I was like, I don't know what's happening. Oh shit
So
Wait, even I can go. No, I can't climb. It's not easy to do anything
All right, let's just go up. Oh, there you go. You're gonna go. Oh, there we go. Okay. Well
Amazing babe keep at it girl. You got this you got this curious to victory
Good job
Help me
I'm pulling it's not working
Sophie try jumping. Oh, there you go. That was so weird. Why can't I pull you forward?
You're too weak. I like it. Maybe I am because all these characters like kind of have their own thing
I didn't even know that
I can't jump up
Oh
All right, let's uh, let's jump over here. Oh, we might have to make our way back around
Yeah
No, I just got up here, you guys didn't have to follow me. I just wanted to see if I can get up
No, I'm not I'm just telling you where to go and how to do stuff
We don't
We're just standing here looking here. Are you mad? Oh, you're the I'm the mad. I'm okay. This is just typical platforming
Great. Okay. Maybe we can do three two one countdown. No, okay. Oh
I'm falling off the blocks of tofu
Oh
He's
I'm being pulled down
And come up here, please
I'm getting pulled down
I'm trying I'm trying I'm trying
Okay
You have to swing
I'm so exhausted
Okay, just swing a little bit to get
Oh
Not even kidding I'm trying to pull myself up and I legitimately back to the car
You
Don't worry guys
Best driver in a back at it again
Gotta play mario car with you guys. I swear
Oh my god, I lost so hard my chest
Oh
Are you doing this on purpose?
So fast
Anything
Oh my god, I left so hard
Oh my god, I didn't look at this. What are you going up there? I want to see that
I missed
Okay, this one's hard to mess up this one's hard to mess up. Don't say that
I'm saying we all just fucking fall off
Okay, come on just this one's easy to
There you go. Yeah. Yeah. We got this
Yeah, best climbers na
Oh, I'm my eyes are actually blurred from laughing so hard
I can't
I'm in the wall. I'm in the wall
Till sweat dropped down my balls
These females crawl I can't jump off because these two girls are dangling like my nutsack get up here
No, we can't
I can't
There we go
Thank you
Oh, where's oh, it's right behind us. Okay
Your toes are cold. She just
I did that I changed characters and I was wondering if I could go back to being an old guy
Oh, wait, it was you changed characters because you clicked on wait. What?
Where are you going?
Look all around. The last time I stood in there is when I noticed I changed characters
So I thought maybe if I did it again, I could be the old guy. Maybe I don't know why I changed you
Maybe you gotta get to another checkpoint. Oh my god. Why can't we all be an old guy?
I well, I don't want to be old and ugly. I don't want to be old. You're saying I'm old and ugly
He doesn't look that way. Look at that model. He definitely gets bitches. Look at him
I'm pulling you all towards me. Emmy. You're lucky. You're on the other end or I'd pull you and dangle you off
All right, let's not hit okay countdown
Yeah, do the countdown. Okay. One two three go. Oh, okay, or we can press. I thought we were gonna press stop
Oh
Stop press the r button. Thank you. Okay
Okay, okay
Okay, I like how you're jumping at
Just go on without me. Just go. Oh, oh, I'm good. Listen. I can't see very well right now. Okay
Get a napkin
No, no, I'm bottling it. I'm bottling it. You're bottling your tears
Yeah, all right. Now you can just run now. We're good. No. Yeah, we're fine. Well, just be mindful be mindful where people are
I can't see
Do it do it do it piss piss piss
Yes
Very to me you're very cutesy very to me you're a very cute. See piss
Just a little bit of piss just a tinkle. Okay, I guess we're just going
Well, these words are a little bit easier. Oh my god. Or maybe not. Maybe maybe it's not so easy
Oh, no. Oh, no, not sopralto not sopralto at the end. Sopralto, please
Please I got you. Okay. I can't help. It's gonna have to do. Oh my god. This is hard
You're gonna have to do it. You're gonna have to pull viv. You're gonna have to pull viv. I'm trying. I'm trying
No, you're fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine
Okay, let me turn around let me turn
There we go, okay, thank god
I'm at the end. It's not my fault. All right. There's a trampoline. Be mindful of it. Okay. Be very to me. You are
It will be mindful
Okay, ready? Are you serious? Are you serious?
Are you serious?
Wait, actually
No, no.
I said oops. I said oops
All right. Let's let's jump on to this rock ladies
Okay.
Lead the way, any one of you.
It doesn't matter which direction you go in.
Oh, there are dead ends.
He's not letting me.
But you'll see the dead ends, because it'll just won't let you move forward.
We gotta wait to stop you.
Okay.
You fucking hell!
What just happened?
Okay.
So you guys want to play?
Oh, no, this is the nearest safe location.
I tried to teleport to the nearest safe location.
So should we go in the easy mode?
Wait, there's no safe point?
No, I don't see one in any of those settings.
Chad, can we go to easy mode now, please?
Chad, can we have permission for easy modes?
I don't think we should.
Wait, does it have to be the person who's running the thing to do it?
I think we have to restart it.
Okay.
Chad, can we do it?
No.
Please.
That was so funny.
Okay, quiet.
My flavor is struggling right now.
Everybody is in like two frames per second.
Mm-hmm.
We're in PowerPoint mode, literally.
They're so funny.
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's gonna be the same.
Oh, wait, if I type in the password, oh, no, they can't see.
Okay, that's good.
Just get rid of it real quick.
Get rid of what?
Just tell me.
Just do it.
Okay, same password, same password,
and it's gonna be beginner mode.
Yeah, okay.
Should I do close chain?
No.
I don't know what that means.
We're all connected to each other rather than being like a line.
Yeah, we're all connected to each other.
No, don't do that.
Wait, wouldn't it be easier?
No.
Wait, did you open the thing?
Oh, we're just inpatient, sorry.
There you go, you can join.
Should we all be old men?
Yes.
There's Steve from Minecraft.
I'd rather be a hag, honestly.
Is there even a hag?
I think there is a hag.
Wait, wrong password?
Oh, shit.
What did you do?
I swear I put the same password.
Let me just check what I wrote in there.
Did you spell it wrong?
I wouldn't do that.
I'm gonna join last so I can be at the end.
Close to game.
Yeah, you need your goats at the end, huh?
You know what?
The two mommies need to be the front and the caboose.
That's better.
Well, that would mean that me or...
Sandwiches.
I require mommy milk.
Please, I'm a baby.
No.
Okay, I made it again.
I don't think I've ever lost.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom real quick.
Don't start the game without me.
Don't start the game without you?
Drag her along.
Just drag her along.
Yeah.
I can't get in.
You got to refresh it.
It says refresh password again?
Hold on, let me refresh.
You guys not spell the password?
No.
Okay, I'm in.
I think you just had to refresh it.
Yeah, I had to refresh the entire thingy.
No, I want to be an old guy.
He looks like his name is like...
If I'm a buff guy, will I be able to carry people better?
Like pull people up?
No, I don't think so.
I need to go to the bathroom too.
Let's see.
You know when you load it in, I thought it said skibbity.
Wow, I can't believe you've said that.
I'm so sorry. The brain rot.
No, it's okay. I'll say it.
What the shibbity a lot, so it's fine.
What the shibbity?
We can't even start the game without her.
She thinks we can.
I would have dragged both of them, honestly.
Same. And blamed them if we could.
Look at their little bodies.
They look so cute.
I just realized,
Sepralta's ears flick. That's really adorable.
That is really cute.
And then Amy has a snot bubble when she sleeps,
but I do too.
You do?
Yeah, Rigger did that.
I don't know if it'll work, because I might have taken it off.
Yeah, I did.
Sometimes if I just go off to the side too far,
I just fall asleep.
It's like how Emmys is right now.
Man, she's a long piss.
You know, some people wash their hands.
I did wash my hands.
You want to smell them?
I bet you just crack your hands with the water.
You don't even put soap on it.
No, I use Bath and Body Works soap.
She dips her hands in the toilet after.
You know when I was crazy?
Me?
No.
You know,
sometimes
if you have
the toilet
and if it's too
forceful or too powerful,
the water will splash up.
Are you talking about when we sit on the toilet
and we piss hard, the water will splash back on us?
No, when you're flushing it.
Sometimes it gets on the seat.
Yeah.
So it happens in public restrooms sometimes.
If I see that,
I immediately just go to a different bathroom.
Same.
I can't deal with that.
Just piss.
Don't sit down. Just squat.
I don't like squatting.
I'll just bare ass it.
I can't squat.
I mean, I can, but I don't like it.
So you'll bare ass stick your ass on a nasty toilet seat if you had to?
No, I just hold it.
I'll do it.
The only time I squat is in a porta potty
because hell no.
I don't have it in me to use a porta potty.
I think I'd rather pee.
When I went to a run fair, I had to use a porta potty
because I was literally going to piss myself.
You could have bottled it.
I don't, I did not have a bottle nearby.
I've had to pee in a cup for a doctor's appointment
before and I hated it.
Peeing in a cup is fun.
It makes a little fun noise.
No, because you have to be nervous
because then I can pee and then they're like,
are you done yet? And I'm like, no.
I just go into Zen mode
and I breathe deeply
and then I just like piss.
Yeah, I just go as you
and then as I blow out, I piss.
Okay, but you have to like piss or like a gentle pisser.
I'm a gentle pisser.
Wait, how do you, what's the difference?
I just let it dribble.
You know, I don't have to force it.
What?
I have a great pelvic floor strength though.
Don't get it twisted.
No, no, I believe you. I believe it's great.
You think it feels nice to force it out?
Yeah, it does a hundred percent.
I love like if you just like really piss really hard.
You're like, ugh.
Just, what is he?
How hard I can piss?
Try to check it in there.
Pissing all by yourself, handsome.
Oh my god.
Yes, you want to hold my hand like this.
Yeah, I think Viv has met her match.
Oh wow.
Me and Viv, I see a lot of myself in Viv.
You know, because we're old.
No!
You're a hag.
Viv is a hag.
Hags are in demand.
Maybe not, maybe other hags.
I don't know about you.
Look at us all running in sync.
I'm pretty proud of us.
You stop.
I dropped something, but I don't know where it is.
Is it this big rock?
Is it your boobs?
You drop your pocket.
You will see me in Japan.
My boobs, I'm pretty sure, are bigger than yours.
I could teach you, but I have to charge.
My boobs are great.
What the fuck?
You felt each other's boobs?
How do you know they're softer?
We're gonna, in October, we're gonna...
Do you still have in Japan?
No.
Yeah? No?
I don't want to see her.
You don't want to see her?
She's mean to me.
You're kind of mean back though.
You're very sun.
She's just bark.
She's mean.
You're my soulmate.
No, we're twin flames.
Because we're...
Nice callback.
Love that.
The underworld.
Already off you a great start, ladies.
We were taking the shortcut.
We are!
We're just not ready for it.
Okay.
At least now when we fall off, we'll start back up here.
You think we lost the brain though?
Probably.
What were you guys talking about?
We were talking about how long we were pissing,
and then we were just talking about pissing in general,
and then like pissing in the club.
And we were talking about porta-potties,
and how we hate porta-potties.
Do you squat or do you bear ass a toilet,
or do you put a little liner down at me?
It really depends.
I never really squat though.
If it's too dirty, I just don't go.
Exactly.
But what if you have to?
Then I'll piss on the fucking floor and add to the mess.
I'm kidding.
I'm just kidding.
Do you guys see that tick-tock of the girl
that shot herself in Walmart?
What?
She recorded a tick-tock of her crying,
and she's like,
guys, I just shot myself in Walmart.
Of course it happens at a Walmart.
And then apparently...
There's somebody who was like,
I saw someone shit.
Yeah!
Someone else made another tick-tock.
Guys, I just...
I love it when there's like
tick-tocks of multiple
angles and stories
of the same thing.
Yeah!
Oh my god.
I think the power
of us talking about piss and shit
is making us play really good.
I know, we're not even thinking.
We're just going.
We're just so focused.
Yeah.
More piss and shit talk.
Oh, never mind.
I think it's or because we're all old moms.
Maybe.
Maybe it's the power of VIV.
I don't know, I just fell off.
He really fell off, sis.
He couldn't handle it.
What did weight girls actually shit?
Oh, uh...
Something.
We do something like the male equivalent,
but it's not quite shitting.
You know like how owls like puke out the bones?
Yeah, we grind stuff
like gizzard and then we throw it up.
Yeah, that's basically what girls do.
Oh, no.
We're good, guys.
We're good. We got this.
And even if we fall off, we have the checkpoint
stuff, so it's not a big deal.
We got it. Keep going to the
side.
Go, no stop.
Go for it, everyone.
Oh, I keep forgetting you can sprint.
Sprint!
Come on, use your old man legs.
Pull me.
Pull me to victory.
He held back my shoe.
I'm seeing some problems with this bangle.
I'm trying to go forward.
And she's just like not moving.
Go, our leader.
Our fearless leader.
Me? Yes, you're the fearless leader.
Cute girls go first.
Cute girls first.
Me and Viv go last because we're hacks.
We're old.
I'm 56 years old.
My birthday is coming up. I'm turning 57.
Not forever 56.
You wear diapers?
Yeah, I dabble.
Do I sell those diapers?
Do I sell them?
You only have $2.
You can't afford them.
I can pay in other ways.
Your body?
Wait, where are we going?
Wait a second.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
We're diaper talking.
Yeah, I was wondering too.
Yeah, I can sell you a liver.
Can you sell them on eBay?
I can do that.
I like to make works of art
with the remnants of what's inside.
I feel like Etsy.
Yeah, Etsy.
You know those scary terms of service?
Abadazzle.
That's why we keep it on the DL.
It's a secret operation.
Secret biohazard.
That's what the store is called. How did you know?
We are the old men.
We're quadruplets.
We are the retirement home.
Stop it, you're a son of a bitch.
Sorry mom.
We were ready, we were ready.
We did the time.
Victoria's fire hazard.
I can't get up.
Help me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go.
Okay.
That was pretty good.
This one, this one, this one.
I think we got to just say this one.
Send it.
Remember you can sprint.
Yes.
I'm still proud of us.
Wait, why did I just fall off?
Can I sprint up the ladder?
Wait, is there a timer?
No, that's just how much time has taken us so far.
Only six minutes.
Yeah, that's not bad.
Because people probably speedrun this.
Yeah, probably.
Oh yeah, we're speedrunning this.
Wait, let me try it.
This game is actually really long.
Can you guys pause real quick?
Yeah.
Let me turn.
Why are you?
Look how it is posted.
Are you like that?
The spread eagle.
The what?
Oh, the spread eagle.
Do you guys ever watch Chicago?
No.
Chicago.
Wait, is it the...
Wait, no.
It's the one where it's like cellblock tango.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
And then her like sister and her husband
were doing the spread eagle.
Ready?
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
I didn't know.
Describe it more in detail though.
I just always thought spread eagles
and your legs are just like in the air like spread.
I don't know.
Is that not what it is?
No, no, no, it is what it is.
But that was like also help.
I'm stuck behind the ladder.
I keep getting stuck on stuff.
Thank you.
This is why I'm not the leader. I'm too dependent.
I will jump off right now.
Do not touch me.
Do it, do it, jump.
Jump.
Wow.
I'm so anti-limactic.
Do it.
It's like you're chocolate.
Okay.
Amazing timing.
Okay, now.
Okay.
I'm going all this way.
We're not that dumb.
We still got six brains.
I mean eight.
Did we get each?
No.
We lost you because we missed the number the first time
and then we had talked about this.
Oh, my game is lagging.
Oh, pause.
Let me fix your game.
Pause.
Die.
Go.
I'm feeling chaotic.
Go, go, go, go.
This actually works out.
See?
That was fine. I just dangled off the side.
It works out.
Because if you do the balancing
and two people are on one side
and two people are on the other,
you can get under some of the obstacles.
Oh, I didn't mean to fall off.
Sorry.
All right.
Ready?
Go, I guess.
Oh, my God.
Where am I going?
I can't tell which one's me anymore.
Okay, let's go Hag Squad.
It's this way.
That's right. We go up here.
How do we Hag Squad?
What's the mail version of Hag?
Just hold me in.
OG Sun.
OG Sun Squad.
Let's go.
Nice.
I wasn't looking.
Come on, fellow.
Don't go yet.
I'm so sorry.
Remember, you want to run ahead and then jump.
It's fine. Just do the press the button.
Press the button.
Oh, highest unlocked point.
Oh, my God.
Is that so much better?
Wait, what happened?
What happened?
Why are we all there?
What the heck?
Do you want to do it again
to see if we change again?
Okay.
Oh.
No.
Oh, my God.
The OG Sun Squad is now just down to one.
Oh, wait.
Back out.
Go.
Jump.
Oh, fuck.
It's fine.
Don't worry. I've got you.
I got you.
I want some ice cream, but I'll probably die.
I'm just craving. Maybe I should get some sherbert.
Because I'm alert.
Well, I'm not allergic,
but I'm definitely intolerant.
But there's milk and sherbert.
Is there?
Sorbet, sorry.
I think you mean sorbet.
Sorbet, sherbert, all the same to me.
When sherbert has milk sorbet, it does not.
Why are we all?
What are we doing?
We're all just baiting each other.
What is happening here?
We're just like, do we go now?
No, now?
No.
Okay, ready?
Go.
That was so funny to me.
You guys just running back and forth.
Don't touch the thing.
I did it.
I touched it.
I touched it again.
I did it.
Quick, do it.
Hit the button.
Okay.
Okay, we got this.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Yeah, just go, go, go, go, go.
There you go.
Speedrun, go, jump.
Go.
I went too early.
Wait, wait, wait.
Grab the hook.
Okay.
Yay!
I think I was about to climb off.
Just climbed up just to get taken off.
Here we go.
We're heading to the car.
The car.
Oh, the car.
There's a little bit more, but then there's the car.
Best driver bib has it.
I have a feeling she's going to lose this time.
Wait, wait, wait.
Do you want to, I kind of want to watch
Amy or Sopalto try to drive now that we have the checkpoint.
Yeah, you're right, you're right.
I don't have a driver's license.
I don't know if I qualify.
I mean, this is your training right here.
Yeah, this is the test.
Okay, I'll drive.
Go ahead, Amy.
Get in the back, ladies.
We're going shopping.
It looks like old man just driving us.
How do I turn?
You did it, you got it?
Oh, I have to be moving forward to turn.
Yup, yup.
It's a little tricky.
It is harder than it looks.
Oh boy.
I won't be running into every single one of these.
Excuse me.
Proceeds to hit one.
I won't, I won't.
You got to go faster to avoid them.
They actually don't really knock you off.
They kind of just bop you.
Oh, nice job.
Thread in the needle.
Ah! Ah! Ah!
Ah! Ah!
What the f...
What just happened?
Stay calm, stay calm.
I'm letting you see both of us and...
Stay where you're staying!
I'm letting you see!
Maybe it's because we're on easy mode.
No, even on easy mode, you can fall off.
That's so weird.
We made it!
Thanks for the design.
You did that.
You're very welcome.
I can't, my face hurts.
That one.
And...
Jump.
Jump again.
And I'm gone.
And then we did.
Wait.
I'm gonna make it.
Oh, okay.
Sopralto. Wait.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, we don't need you.
I'm gonna be really funny if Sopralto...
Wait.
Let's do it.
Wait. Oh, okay.
Let's see if Sopralto can do it.
Come on.
Come on, Sapikins.
Okay.
Oh, you're going fast.
Oh, she's zooming.
Hit it.
Kill him.
Don't actually kill him.
Okay, keep going.
Oh, she's driving backwards.
That takes skill.
I'm trying to figure out how to reverse.
There you go.
Three point turn.
Don't drive us into the hole.
Okay.
Oh, don't make me laugh.
I'm gonna mess it up.
You probably were gonna mess it up anyways.
But, yeah.
No, it'll happen.
No, maybe guinea pigs shouldn't drive.
No, you're doing it.
She's doing it.
We're going backwards.
Are you threatening to kill us?
What's happening?
Turn.
Don't act like this.
Please.
Turn, turn.
Turn.
See, I told you you can get knocked off.
Just drive backwards.
Turn around.
Oh, can we restart this part?
No, you can do this.
I believe in you.
Just drive backwards.
I can't see backwards.
You can't see?
Just turn your camera.
Wait, I got it.
Wait, I can use the ramp to help me.
Oh, my God.
What are you doing?
Mario Karting.
I can't believe this happened again.
You got this?
I don't want to do these things.
Great.
Baby, pull this back.
No.
All right.
Well, now we know how that was going to go.
Yeah.
Oh.
Okay.
I didn't know what to do.
Can you pull?
I'm trying.
I wish they had little dance moves.
Like a little form.
Like I could e-boat.
Like the orange justice here.
Exactly.
This is me dancing.
Oh, my God.
I'm laughing again so hard.
I'm doing a little bit of a chat, though.
I'm crying.
This is the best part.
This is not a good dance.
Maybe if we were talking about piss, I would have done better.
Okay.
I miss.
What's your favorite flavor of piss?
Apple juice.
Red.
Oh.
Red?
I like mine a little spicy.
Oh, please stop falling off.
I could drive again.
My turn.
Did she get in the front?
Who's in the front right now?
I'm in the front.
It's me.
Okay.
Thank goodness.
Why am I going backwards?
I'm in the front.
You are?
Wait, what?
Oh, I thought I was driving.
What are you doing?
Wait, who's driving?
Me.
Are you really?
Seriously?
I was like, wait, that can't be.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's sloppy.
Yeah, that's happy
I've never gotten pulled over and I have a really good lesson. It's just not in hell
I don't know if that's true. I think you're lying to us. I think you're like driver's license is fake
Did you die in a car crash? Is that how you got to hell?
She crashed a car. She had like 50 pedestrians
He's like just hitting a strike. You ever thought about that?
I'm stuck. Alright, my turn
I
Think it's how entertained we are by this car
I wish I could jump and do flips can I go faster? No, this is the max you can go
It's because you're just a bad driver, babe
Sorry freeze old
I was doing pretty good. I was going I was going no stop. Okay. I almost made it to the end somebody's a decent driver here, you know, not you
You
They do you get stuck on some things, but some things they don't get stuck on which is
Okay, I'm ready
I'm ready to throw myself off the cube
Okay, I have already thrown myself off the cube
I'm on the cube. I'm on the cube
I'm no longer on the cube
I'm on the cube. I'm jumping off the cube
I was one
Okay, so now we'll respond like right here. So it's fine
You're like a side character
One that dies on episode three and you motivate you motivate everybody else
She's the Mabel sacrifice
I can't
Can't
I almost as far did it cuz I was laughing so hard
Jump up my head is too big
See it's hard we have to like go over here and yeah
Yeah, it's easier from the little platform
I
Mean
And we have the giggles too much it's getting harder
Oh, I can see my insides I did not like that
You can see your inside. I like a like clip so that I could see my inside of my model. It was kind of scary
It's doing it again. I can see inside my pants and I get the chain looks like looks like so if you back up against this and
Like push your mouse forward. Oh, it looks like guts. Yeah with the chain. Yeah
Okay chains and whips excite me
What the fuck was that
Oh
And me the true gamer
Wow, we're doing so great
Like every holding all these chains, I look like I'm making something
Goodbye wait, are we grunting are we?
There's a grunt the character grunts when they jump
I hear like oh
Oh my god, I think those noises with you. Oh
I
Don't want to make those noises. I don't think I'll ever leave these noises down if I make them. Hell. They're not that bad
I mean, they'll be in private me and you and maybe a few other people
I'm literally gonna cry, please
Oh
It's better than a cube let's think up. Let's lock in everyone
Sorry it said go so I
Okay
You can you cannot press the button
Oh
Okay, you can hit that you can hit the thing
The only driving that was majestic I'm sorry. Oh, wow. Oh, I see how it is. I'm just
No, you're already sold your liver to me. I didn't mean to fall
I can't
Okay, okay, no autopilot we just we go okay, okay, okay, I'm locked in
I'm tightened
Missed my jump
We're doing so good right now
Just jump to the box, it'll be easier to pull so
Okay
I'm swinging I'm up
All right, now we can just kind of go only two of us are hags
No, there's only there's only one OG sand here
Are you telling me elderly
Yes, just because I have boobs doesn't mean I'm elderly. I also have going along you. No, she doesn't she's smaller than me
Don't lie, she's a sham
Okay, I have
Fucking giant titties bro. She isn't not lying at all. She's not a scam like you are. I'm I'm scamming. I'm a liar
And me also as fat titties
It's time it's time it's time by the way, so let's let's just wait a moment
Yep, yes, it is mm-hmm, and we're only gonna go higher
Mm-hmm, do you think we can finish the game? No, no
This game is so much bigger. There's a whole other level before this after this one. Okay
Yeah jump just try not to vault just try to jump it's hard. I actually know it yeah, I give up
I can't even follow my own fucking advice
Oh
I'm ready. Yes. Go. Oh, okay
Sorry to the countdown ready
Oh
Go get to the get to the elevator another elevator
Cute
Thank God
You could like fall off of it
We did it gang
Welcome to the whispering balls I got an achievement me to reach the mysterious cave
Oh
If you guys want to explore feel free there's nothing but go ahead. No, I'm good
Don't worry. No. Yeah
The elevator is very safe
Okay, so be careful because there might be a spot where you can fall through are we naked
No, oh and my it looks like we're naked
Wait, oh you can die. Yes. Oh do we do we drown? No? No, I already did
Oh
True true true. Oh, wait. No, I don't think we're at that water spot yet. Where you have to like swim around all and go
Why are we have to run there's something chasing
They should do that they should add like a monster that chases you so it's like scarier. Yeah. Yeah
Very safe
It's funny you what you guys look like when you look up
Oh, wait, our heads actually turn. Yeah, it's kind of funny
Okay, so this is a puzzle
You say oh, what are you serious? It's a puzzle. You have to get the jump and we have to hit the buttons
six brain cells we got this
We have to hit them all. Yes in order to open the door
Okay, where's the next one up here up there?
And then I got it
Then we gotta go to the I can't remember if they're timed or not. Where's the last button? It's on the other side
Where I am I'm I'm I'm in stuff to help me
I can't get up. Where's the last button? It's behind you up here
What
Sorry, miss. Oh, we did it. Nice
Easy peasy lemon squeezy
Okay, now we got to make that that sprint jump ready jump grab
Yep
Okay
We're from the side
I'm going. Oh, no. Oh, no
We're good. We're good. Okay. Wait, wait here
Go down go down
Goodbye
Oh, hey look we're back to the car
No, no, absolutely not. It means hell. It's me driving that car
Okay, there we go
I'm stuck
It's okay. I'm a fairy
She was a fairy
Hi Sophie
Back to the car
You won the car you were obsessed with this car. You just want to drive again. No, I think I just like see
I have a very nice car that you don't use it's a mom van
And you're calling me and Viv the hags. It probably has zero miles on it too. I think it's like 25,000
miles pretty good
I actually don't know what that
Um, I it's how many like it's just how much you've used your car
But also it my parents gave it to me so I could go to college to get more knowledge
And then I chose to become a streamer so you see where I'm happy
Oh gosh
So this is where me is Zura, Apollo and um
Freya got stuck on really hardcore last time and we were raging by the end of the street
Yeah, I go over here. He's got to be mindful of the lasers. Demure very demure very mindful. Okay, be ready to jump
I'm always mindful
Okay, and then we're right here too. Yep, then turn to the side and then go over there. Oh
We're so good at this
We let us finish those first. I mean look at us go
All right, where are we going next to that one that one?
Oh, okay, our massive. We're actually doing a lot better
When I played this last holy crap. It's the piss buff. It's the piss buff. It's the piss buff
Oh
Oh, sorry, I jumped too soon. It's all right. I jumped too soon. Oh my god. Oh my god. This game's breaking me
Almost there. Oh
That was backed up so far. I fell off
Okay
We did it. You guys couldn't do that. Yeah, we couldn't for some reason
They didn't have the joint chemistry that we do our brain cells
I think it was this one actually that we we had it because we when you fall you have to start back
Yeah
Yeah, but you have to start back at um this part
Because it's the same level technically that's why
How long have we been doing this 147 45
Oh
141 45
So 147 is close enough you round me
I don't like
I missed
Oh, we were about to fall perfectly in that hole
I felt perfectly in your your hole last night
I felt perfectly in your mom's hole last night. I was gonna say that
I was gonna say that but I don't want to put your mom into this and now I see that we're allowed to
Of course we are mom's fair game
Like she was last night
Me and emi straight the same two brain cells apparently ready
Yes, okay, don't miss
I didn't even get to jump I like someone fell into it
I jumped on top of it. I'm sorry. It's okay. I can't be mad at you. It feels soppy. I would have been pissed
I'm gonna jump off the I'm gonna jump off the map right now. Don't touch me
Do it. I'll pee in your fucking suit
Don't test me. I'm fully off laughing
You see what I have to do is she's so mean to me
Is that mean or me defending myself? It's kind of hot. You guys should kiss
We are we're gonna hold toes our toes. You're gonna get a lot in our locked toes
You know a little crazy thing. I actually don't like people touching my feet
Really?
Oh my god
You haven't had me touch your feet. Okay. You don't know what it's like
One time I went to get a massage and I told the lady not to touch my feet because I felt felt weird about it
I just don't like people touching my feet. I don't know. I've just been a thing. Do you get ticklish?
No, no, it's just like I get ticklish. I just don't like go go go go the only time I'll let people touch my feet is my pedicurist
And I'll giggle every time and she makes fun of me. Oh, so you're ticklish. I'm extremely ticklish on my feet
Well, you just gave us ammo. What are you gonna do with that?
I'm literally I'm trying to pull up
And I couldn't I was but you saw me pulling it up
You saw me
Literally, I okay, you know, I'm not gonna fall next time and you're just gonna be all your fault
Oh, wait, where are you going?
Sorry, I didn't know where you're going. I was turning on the light. It's dark in my house
You're in the air
Oh, hey worked out
What was that the dangle tech if we're dangling you can't I can't stop. Don't worry about it. Just keep going. Okay. Well, I guess you're going
But there's spikes. That's okay. I'll be fine. Aren't they gonna spike us wait if we jump
We're back at the beginning. I cannot jump
Back to the car
I'm gonna put a blob in your car. Oh my
Yes, the next person who falls what
It's not gonna be me
Did you do that on purpose
It's like I know like ticklishness is a fetish
You know what ticklishness is a fetish? Wait, wait, wait. Okay. Yeah, like, I know some people get off from being like tickled
What? Yeah, yeah
Yeah, it's a thing. It's a thing for sure
You know, I took sexual psychology and I didn't even know that
Really? I mean, I don't think the point of sexual psychology is to teach you about every single kink that exists
No, no, I did learn that there's a difference between a kink and a fetish
Oh, wait, what's the difference?
Uh, a kink is something that amplifies the the the dew, you know
And then a fetish is something like you genuinely need to get off
Oh
So warwick for me. Yes
Okay, okay. Wait, what's warwick?
At least don't don't don't get into that. Have you ever heard of the best game ever league of legend? Oh god
I'm gonna kill myself right now. I'm throwing myself off
With over a hundred and fifty characters you could play
No, it's okay. You don't have to tell me about it
No
That's on me. That's on me
That was me. That was me. That was me. I missed the jump
Okay, okay
That's she be
There's not me this time. I'll have you know, I'm not me this time. Ah jump jump
Hey, we actually I wasn't ready for two dogs at the park and we're just
I have to toot
Do it turn around put it in like
I did it. I did it. No, I'm I'm needed
You guys ever hear about that lady who like went to the hospital because she far she captured her jars or farts and jars
Yeah, yeah, yeah, and then she like ate like a shit ton of beans and stuff too
Wait, why did she go to the hospital for capturing her farts? He farted too much that her like
Her like her tell me herdy really baddie. Yeah, that's me for real for real
But yeah, basically she was like she was selling her farts
And she was farting like over a hundred times a day, I think
Oh, why do I feel like I heard about this
Her her like she was a streamer too
Yeah
It was like last year earlier before it was recent. I wish we could sell our bath water and pee
I don't know about the pee ready
I want to be like Belle Delfine
Do you guys hear that her like bath water contain none of her like actual bath water? I know it's crazy
I was really offended when I got it and I smelled it and it smelled nothing like her
Wait, oh you ordered it
Did you order it?
I'm sorry, I was so thrown off by the whole like bath water thing that I forgot to press space bar
It's okay
Yeah, we're back here who's stopping me the fda. That's who's stopping me from selling my bath water
Yeah, it was like also like here you can't do that. I mean they can't catch you
They don't know if I'm the gingerbread man
exactly
And it doesn't have to be from me being in the bath. It could just be from my bathtub
You know, it's crazy. I I knew someone who genuinely bought her bath water
And like his oh, sorry, that was me
Oh
All right, that's so I bought the like bath water and his girlfriend like broke up with him
Yeah
Yeah, I mean he's drinking my bath water. He's drinking some other bitch's bath water
He's drinking some other bitch's bath water. Are you kidding his girlfriend?
Is like uh like also like a Belle Delfine fan
Oh, but she was like she was she she was
Explain it. Was she jealous that she didn't get it, but he did
No, she because he bought it using the money for like her anniversary present. Oh, oh, yeah. No, yeah, no
Dumped
Wait, so he was saving up money for her anniversary present and instead used it for Belle Delfine bath water. Yep. Yeah, he yeah
And then he like he handed it to one because he bought like multiple
He's like, here's your fucking present
He thought that she would want it because she's you know by icon
And she was like I like Belle Delfine, but I don't want her her bath water and she like broke up with him
Oh, I I decided by it. I just wouldn't want it for a present for anniversary present. That just
I'm like if it's a
Oh
It's okay. We got this we got this. Okay. I'm just gonna shut up and lock in
Okay, gamers silence
Oh
See I locked in I was the only one left standing
That's vips fault. She should have done that. What are you talking about? I didn't do anything
I mean, this is my fault. I didn't make any laugh. We would have been fine
Chat chat. Did I do anything wrong? Yes
Chat said she did everything wrong. This tell her it's all her fault. She's been a bad girl
Help I'm falling
Okay, how did that how did I get knocked off?
Oh, and I have a member stream at 8 8 8 8 p.m
Uh-oh, I mean you're in the same time zone
Eastern time, baby. He's never mind. He's cursed, baby
No, where are where are we last attempt last attempt then look at his fine ass right there. He's flexing it. It's pretty flat
I like my ass. Who are we looking at right now?
We're looking at you
Sopralto not me the listen to her
Why do you use my full government name every single time because I like saying your name. It's actually really appealing to say it for me
I like to say Sopralto Sopralto. It's like I'm stimming so my word stem is your name
Sopralto Sopralto Sopralto
You can say my name if we make it
Okay, as a treat. All right, daddy. Okay
Okay, baby girl. Why do you want me to call you meow for me kitten? Meow meow
We weren't ready. Don't go yet. Don't go yet. Don't go yet. Okay ready
Let's use that voice changer. Yeah
Sorry
I'm just really nervous right now. I get so nervous around you
It's so hard
Oh, no, this is a hard one. It's okay. It's okay. This is the last one. I know this is a hard one
Oh
What
Wait, what was that white woman jump scare voice? Can you do that again?
My white my white woman jump scare voice. That's my normal voice. What are you talking about? No, I want to hear it say say it again
It's like an advertisement. Yeah, I'm actually like very interesting
Now that you guys know I'm blushing I can't do it do it do it
Because I'm very impressed with your voice acting skill and I want to be able to copy it
And absorb your skill like fucking misty comex man
You a twilight you a twilight sparkle voice go I am not doing the twilight sparkle do it
Oh my god, I just realized your hair is exactly like twilight sparkle
You're literally twilight sparkle
I'm begging you, please don't make me do this
We're gonna stand here and stare at you. I don't think I can do it right now
Okay, then just say hi. My name is twilight sparkle and I'm the princess of friendship
My name is twilight sparkle and I'm the princess of friendship
You've done the voice. Don't make me pull up your I'll pull up your file. Let's go make me pull up your file
You're standing on nothing
You don't you don't have to shit
I'll find it
I'll find worse
You'll find me talking about warwick and how much I want him to fill me up with this pub
You twilight sparkle voice and I'll play dead by daylight with you
Okay, what's another voice you can do I'm very interested in your voice acting skill, please I I'm I'm I'm I'm hyper fixated now
Ha ha ha
My white woman voice
Do the white woman voice then I have it. It's like it comes out when it comes out. She comes out
The white woman within me. That's my customer service. Let's talk about mlms right now then
Males love males
Male of male
My mom lost fell for it and went bankrupt. Oh my god. Oh my god. That's crazy
I know male pregnancy is kind of hard
What male of monday male love monday. Yeah male love monday
Shout out to all the males out there in the audience
You want to hear about it? Yeah, we I was reading this is the farthest I've gone
Sure
Yeah, where do we go?
There's a sword. I think we go. Oh sword. Oh, oh
Or I don't know. I don't know. Oh, emmy emmy's doing something. Is this a is this a hack?
You can avoid the sword. I don't
F the sword man
Walk on the but uh, I was reading a yaoi recently
And it was so it was about this like
Kind of like a pretty boy
and then um
There's a delinquent boy and they were childhood friends
With this one guy who's like the honorable student, but they all go to different
Oh my god. I know what you're talking about and I read and then they're like they're like
You're you're uh, are you at top or bottom? Is this like omega versus shit?
No, no, no, I can't get up or an omega
So are you top or bottom and then you don't pull me up just keep going just keep going
It's fine. No, I think I'm gonna follow
Amy jump off the other side
I'm trying
And now we just wiggle
Wiggle yeah
Swing swing just for swinging
It's working
Oh, it's actually kind of working. You're right. Hold on
That's like one of those toys where you have to like avoid touching the edge or you'll get shocked
Hold on. I'm getting it. I'm getting it
What the fuck?
Yeah, it's working. It's how is she not falling off
Okay, I'm not gonna swing then because I don't want to accidentally swing her off
Hello, wait, you could probably teleport us back there. Oh, yeah
I did good, okay
She's so proud of herself. I did good
I'm so proud of you. You're the satisfaction in your voice
How
Okay, let me go first. Hold on. Let me go first. Let me go first. Let me go first. Hold on. Let me just jump on
Please hold. Okay
All right, it's fine just swing on the other side
Hold on. Hold on. I'm let me swing across so I can get onto this rock
It's because I'm falling for you. I don't know what to say. I just I'm just so in love
Let me see if I can even replicate what I did before the Riz master. Oh, yeah. Oh, never mind. It's more like a double day
Okay, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Let's see. Do you still want to go first? Okay. Hold on. Locked in. Locked in. Locked in.
Walking in. I fell. It's okay. Locked in. Smash W
Just like I'm gonna smash her mom
Making fun of how we walked earlier now
Yeah
I don't think I want to smash them all now speed up gas pedal gas pedal gas pedal
I'm sorry
I'm dying. Yeah, right in my mouth, please
Oh, it changed on man
Happy
Oh, we're we're doing so good right now. Yeah, what the hell?
Don't say that as I fucking fall off and kill us all
You know, I'll catch you
We're doing much better than I thought we would yeah, it's because we're doing the
I accidentally muted my mic
When I played with bibb, she like
I'll tap forward right away
Really? Why do you make it sound like I give up? I'm not a giver upper. All right. I gotta go
I really don't want to but I gotta go spend time with the boys. Can we save this?
Can we save and retry another time? Yeah, it says save and quit games. So I'm guessing
Oh, we could do it another time. You guys want to schedule it for some time in the future?
Sure. Sure. That was just fun
It was vibing
It's like we had a podcast as we're like in hell
Okay, that's our podcast. Okay, we'll message and we'll figure out when we're all free again
Yeah
Okay, thank you for playing with me
Thank you so much. Bye guys
Thanks for inviting me
Yippie all right
Thank you guys for your understanding and I can't get out of here
We're all just looking at each other still. How do I how do I leave?
They're really they're really cool
Um
Evie
Evie asked in the um
In the group chat if uh anybody wanted to play and stuff and I was like, yeah, why not?
um
And I'm happy I did because like I immediately headed off with uh, soppy
Soppykins. I'm gonna call her soppykins because although I do like saying her full government name
Um
And oh, he is so cute. She's like very sleepy next to me. Oh, hi boomie. Boomie just showed up. But yeah, I'm glad that um
Mia mercy suggested that I play um when emi asked in our discord. So I was like, yeah, I'll do it. I was fun. I was
I keep saying her full name. It's a power move soppykins like he's a cat exactly. Um
If they really they remind me a lot of us like, uh
That and they have another friend too and they literally just remind me of veeler
I feel like I feel like it's like the alternate universe of us
Fe is holding my hand and she's licking my arm. She's literally has my
Her paws wrapped around my wrist and is locking me in place to lick my hand. Um, but that was really funny
Um, thank you guys for understanding
Being late with the member stream. I'm sorry. Uh, let me go set that up right now
And I'll see you guys in a couple of minutes. And if you're not a member do it. We're watching scary movie together
You're so we're gonna giggle even laugh even more
Okay
Bye
Bye see you in a little bit
Yeah, oh wait, let me
I'm gonna read
Let's find someone to read. Don't forget I have their stuff in the description
So make sure you uh, you you subscribe to them. They're very funny
I can't where's the where's the redirect?
Okay, there's a lot of people streaming right now
Should I just raid emmy?
Is emmy still playing? Are they still playing?
Can somebody answer that question for me? Are they gonna keep playing?
I don't know. I don't know if they're gonna. No, I think they're just any extreme as well. Okay. I'm gonna send you
I'm gonna send you to yay you giri because she's playing some game called don't pee and she just started
And I think that's
That's very on topic so you guys can just say piss raid piss raid piss raid piss raid. Um, wow, that's like extremely fitting so have fun
I think it's a game about trying not to pee
All right, bye guys, I'll see you in a little bit
I'm literally gonna end this stream
and then start the um
the member stream